as a property investor you need to be
able to do your due diligence on a
property
and part of doing due diligence is
knowing what the
address of a property is so like
literally these houses
you know without knowing what the
address is how can you do any due
diligence you've just got
koley oxford oxford that's it
so if you ring up the estate agent and
you ask them for the address they're not
going to give you the address they're
going to say
they're going to sell you on doing a
viewing so as a professional property
investor i like to know the house number
i want to know the full postcode
before i even bother picking up the
phone and bringing the agent how do you
how do you find out the door number how
do you find out the full address well
there's a few little tricks you can do
i mean the first thing is if you pretend
that you're trying to get broadband show
broadband average speed
okay you need to do this on a computer
not on an iphone it won't work on an
iphone but if you're on a laptop
and you you know you're looking at this
house you want to know the address
go and compare them the market ask what
the broadband speed is
and then room back out shallow just like
that there we go that's the postcode
full postcode
ox438 so now you can start doing due
diligence now
you got the postcode that's a little bit
more helpful what about the door number
though well the
actual door number the first thing i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna uh to get the door
number it's pretty advanced but i'm
gonna
zoom in and often you can see the door
number on the front of the door it's
literally that simple now in this
occasion you can't
there are there is no door number or
they've blurred it so i'm going to then
start looking at the wheelie bins
ah nothing
no door number all right cool there's so
many ways to do it i can't how about
this go on market info
i can see the last time this house sold
was in 2001 for 143
and 500 pounds so if we go to
sold properties or sold house prices
we know what the postcode is so we can
put the postcode in
ox43hx
let's find the property so we sold for
143
and 500 pounds so i'm just going to
scroll down
this is right back to 2001. but i need
to get that door number
because without the door number i'm
going to ah there we go 143
500 pounds in 2001 that's the matching
postcode and boom
21. now we have the actual
road name as well which we didn't even
have before let's just check that's the
right house
let's check it's the same property
you can tell by looking at it it is oh
and back then they had a door number as
well but they took that off because
probably the estate agent blowed that
out they do not want you to know the
door number of these houses we need to
know them as professional property
investors
you get the door number you then start
doing your due diligence
and then if it looks good book a viewing
start offering on properties so there's
a little hack
on how to find the door number there we
go land registry tells you the full
address now
and now we can start doing all kinds of
due diligence
and start putting that in my softwares i
can start finding out the value of it
all kinds of stuff but you need to get
the full address
you ring up the agent they're not going
to give it to you that's why i'm making
this video for you guys
so if this video was helpful please let
me know you liked this video by smashing
the like button
subscribe to the channel so much more
like this coming soon